those eye drops didn't work give him a
sec
it looks like I'm high a little did they
know I was crying cuz of that scene and
liar liar hey guys I'm Ryan right
Melissa be crazy
yeah listen beautiful [__] mine we're
gonna watch a couple of TMNT things
there's a movie clip out and there's
another cool TV spot out wait wait what
wait you should be holding this I should
but it's old tea and the tea bag still
in there is a tea bag so yeah we're
we're gonna watch this these couple
things have you seen any of the trailers
I have not
mostly because I liked the cartoons but
the new breed of mutant ninja turtles
since they started redoing them on
Cartoon Network has really severely
creeped me out because it's like I don't
know if you guys have seen them you know
what I'm talking about it's really
creepy Michelle Michelle I've never seen
it but I understand where you're coming
from
yeah hey I totally understand yeah
Alyssa Alyssa Ryan
tea bag ahh and for you kids you don't
know what that is it's when you dip your
balls in someone's mouth first thing
we're gonna watch the exclusive snow
chase clip you ready Alyssa be crazy I
think I'm ready I don't know how
everybody I can possibly be I'm pretty
ready violet are you ready good
[Music]
what
oh yeah Oh
[Music]
Oh
I was on the train
[Music]
god damn
oh yeah
[Music]
very good looks like a sweet [__]
movie yeah actually if a movie has this
really cool action and I tend to be
satisfied if it's martial arts too
included I get really I'm really happy
with the quality of what it seems to be
yeah cuz I thought it was gonna be kind
of sucky when I first heard about it I'm
like ah they're doing a Tim and E again
but no it actually looks kind of awesome
and you know what I thought okay so I
saw what their faces look like with the
whole nose saying cuz now they have like
nostrils and nothing nostril and I
thought that was like the weirdest thing
ever but then I went over to my friends
house and she has Turtles and I just was
looking at their faces and their noses
are freaking weird and now I don't think
it's that weird anymore cuz like a real
turtles nose is weaker than how that
actually looks have you ever seen a real
Turtles of course I have anyway that's
my thought but on a day I once saw
Turtles making love at the zoo these
giant ass Turtles turtles are tortoises
I might have been tortoise you're
another very different animal I might
have been hosts you know people will get
them confused now and again ELISA don't
try to embarrass me like this there's no
need for confusion here this is a house
of non judgment mm-hmm wait what is this
house is not a word reading a Christian
household then why not talk to me yeah
no I I really like it that I think it
looks really good now the action looks
like it's directed really [__] well
and the fact that like it's like it's
just looks so cool oh you know question
what's that Megan Fox yeah it was that's
why I thought okay I don't like her yeah
a lot of people don't okay yeah not like
I think she's really really freaking
pretty like she's very very pretty but
I'm not a fan of her acting's stylings
yeah I mean she could be better but you
know still I come on her face so that's
what counts
hide
do this house you drip tea everywhere to
Megan Fox let's watch the other TV spot
I think this one's called kicker kicker
or some [__] like that
it's Nickelodeon you step into the wood
you gotta get shell shocked
allow me to be the badass for once
[Music]
yo
misshapen to Nobu
[Music]
the street
yeah dear boy sweet hahaha
Ninja Turtles coming soon how looks like
a lot of fun man it does look like like
a shits out of but I really want to see
it there's a lot of people who are
really hating on this and I'm like hey I
thinks isn't this cuz Michael Bay
produced it and like yeah but you know
what Michael Bay like his movies are
very fun and they're they're not if not
completely serious they're actually just
a fun fun outing like you won't regret
your life afterwards
he'll think it's kind of weird but you
won't like absolutely we write the past
like two and half hours not sure when I
saw Transformers Revenge of the Fallen I
seriously contemplated suicide for about
a good half hour oh speaking of which
speaking of suicide are Merce Michael
Bay and what's your face like never want
to work together again without some kind
of cup what is this then I'd have to
explain the whole thing to you but then
a lot of people would hate on you for
not knowing I'm asking cuz I don't know
I think that's a respectable thing I
hope you guys agree with me like if you
don't know something you asked to learn
and then you know you don't just
automatically gain knowledge you don't
soak it in like a sponge just trying to
protect you there's gonna be people who
are gonna be like that girl's an idiot
cuz she didn't know information prior to
the video it was desiccating to the
video itself I was asking about a
private conflict they had which is not
generally super public knowledge what's
up listen I'm not trying to fight with
you I was just trying to explain I mean
okay if you wanna know if you want to
know I'll look at okay if you want to
know I can tell you I can tell you if
you want to know I don't want to know
the play ass okay maybe you don't maybe
these guys don't know - I'm not saying
all of you but some of you then you'll
appreciate this chat um Megan Fox and
Michael Bay made up oh good I didn't
know that okay yeah that's about as far
as the story goes alright no no you
could have just said that from the
beginning
I could have alright guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe right
here doesn't matter if you're Jewish
Christian or black or white or
[__] from El Salvador or if you're
you know gay subscribe we like all kinds
of people on Herod yeah exactly and
ELISA feels the same way too
except she's a little bit more out of
her [__] mind so subscribe to ELISA
be crazy
this is promotion time promotion
promotional area shameless we look you
in that's what other youtubers have
taught us anyway we're gonna do some
shout outs here Edmund McGinley um now
shut your mouth for one second he said
can i have a shout out for Melissa yes
you asked for shout outs for me
hello edifact McKinley I'm really
curious as to what your origins are cuz
McKinley sounds very I don't know what
do you think that is I want to say
somewhere from Guatemala you think I was
gonna guess something around Irish or
Scottish I don't know for sure though
I'm pretty good when it comes to this
stuff and I'm more than confident it's
more along the water mala alright well
anyway he says her hair looks great in
ponytail thank you I have a habit for me
wash for you happy okay Han just
somebody cover your boobs what are you
doing what are you doing it's about sex
appeal honey that's why reading on the
channel okay
otherwise you just be in the cab cooking
salting
that's not insulting I'm just being a
gentleman ah the faculty gave him
Anthony is really turning me on right
now Dan Edmund get the [__] I'm gonna do
cause there's a perfect wingman Aaron
are Jones he asked a couple times that
if he could get a shout-out cuz he would
feel happy oh I'm gonna be happy we want
you to be happy weren't why you down why
are you down hearing there's no reason
to be blue you should be green don't
wait blues green is envy or say to this
be be pink cuz pink is a happier color
right PLR know what yellow is the color
of sunshine
okay um yeah Erin what she said that's
also good dude Erin um love you man
your you make me happy because you
because we make you happy so in the
natural you know transition the flow
think yeah the flow of happiness
transmitting to one another is what
happens with us my friend
so thank you Erin thank you you're a
good lad
Edmund McKinley Adele drover it's Adele
[__] it down i Ryan you all really
good-looking dude good all boys have a
shot
that's how Adele sounds that's my
impression of Adele Elroy I saw on your
[__] a doddle no cockadoodle
can you please never do that again no it
sounded really uncomfortable
sounded M company yeah you like
uncomfortable for me to do or you became
uncomfortable oh okay
well Adele wanted a shout out and Adele
you know how hot I think you are
come on girl [__] you know where I live
it's come over any time sub Bay even
bring a boyfriend by of my having a
little three-way Alyssa can you record
our threeway my dream girl will not be
here
why would not cuz they both want you
mean if you had the opportunity to see
Adele and I having sex and her boyfriend
having sex with us you wouldn't want to
catch a glimpse of that I would probably
drive back home to San Francisco just to
avoid being in the near area how
insulting if I heard you were going to
give a guy a [__] and people could be
in the room I hope now I care for that
if you're having sex I mean I had kind
of care no no
so I was just imagining you having sex
with someone and I got turned on anyway
del how's your shout out baby